tonight we are nearing the end of joe
biden's first three weeks in office and
the very
weak frail cognitively struggling
president
well he's still lost and confused and
meanwhile his radical green new deal
agenda
is wreaking havoc on what could have
been a robust
v-shaped recovery today jobs report it
wasn't good
our economic growth anemic labor
participation rate has gone down
only 6 000 private sector jobs were
created
even fake news cnn had to admit that it
is a
grim sign for a recovery and to make
matters worse we got thousands
of high-paying career union jobs
instantly vanished
just in the last two weeks after biden
canceled the keystone xl pipeline
with the stroke of a pen and thousands
more
of those jobs also lost uh when they
stopped
border wall construction and guess what
hundreds of thousands or more
those high-paying career jobs will also
be gone
as joe follows through on his promise
and his plan to cancel
all oil and gas pipelines and block
drilling and exploration in anwar
alaska something donald trump opened up
but today at the white house joe biden
openly wondered
where all the jobs go maybe you
shouldn't have gotten rid of them
take a look january job numbers
came out today and while we're grateful
for everyone who found work and
is earning a paycheck it's very clear
our economy is still
in trouble we added just 6 000
private sector jobs in the country last
month
these aren't democrats or republicans
they're americans
and they're suffering they're suffering
not because of anything they did
through no fault of their own their
suffering i see enormous pain
in this country a lot of folks out of
work
a lot of folks going hungry staring at
the ceiling tonight wondering what am i
going to do tomorrow
a lot of folks trying to figure out how
to keep their jobs
a lot of those uh americans suffering
joe
you caused that you got them the pink
slips
you ensured their careers were derailed
their dreams their hopes shattered with
it
and as predicted we're now entering joe
biden's dark
winter and it's only going to get darker
millions out of work no ability to pay
their rent their mortgage health
insurance car
truck payment put food on the table and
this comes
as the biden administration is opening
the floodgates at our southern
border not only did biden stop all the
border wall construction
but now he's reviving the obama area era
policy of catch and release well that
means that
yeah illegal immigrants apprehended at
the border they'll simply be released
right into american cities i wonder if
they'll show up for their court dates
i doubt it and not only does that create
obvious health and security concerns
especially in light of the pandemic but
that also will flood the job market with
cheap labor
at a time when millions of americans are
out of work
which means americans won't be hired and
wages now they have
so many more workers and then 11 million
getting legal status
yeah wages will plummet but fear not
because the biden administration is
working on a plan to send free masks to
americans
hey joe you need to wake up from your
nap because
every american i could i could say
fairly confidently
has a mask or has access to one if they
want one
and of course they also want to wipe out
all student loan debt
for all of those who racked it up this
huge
debt in exchange for a ba you know i
don't know
uh sociology or climate change and
meanwhile joe biden's promise to send
two thousand dollars direct payments to
americans
well that now has been reduced to
fourteen hundred dollar
a fourteen hundred dollar plan to maybe
send payments to
some americans and even far-left actress
susan sarandon she's angry calling biden
out on twitter
if boaters feel like dems are pulling a
bait and switch do not be surprised when
they don't show
up in 2022 or 2024
and while susan is uneasy most of the
radical socialist progresses in the
democratic party
they seem to be elated they don't seem
to care about the high paying career
union jobs wiped out
or direct payments to americans because
they're focused on something
much bigger and that is satisfying their
rage their psychosis
their hate against donald trump and they
have to save the planet because
ocasio-cortez says
we only have 12 years and they believe
joel biden is meeting this critical
moment
by giving pink slips to a lot of
american workers take a look
i'd like to get your grade your
assessment and reaction to these first
few weeks of the biden presidency
well keep in mind joe biden ran
on the most progressive agenda
ever and now he is meeting
the moment and we need to continue to
hold everyone
accountable to the promises that have
been made
it's a good time so let us state the
obvious one more time the radical
socialists that run the democratic party
that are in charge they're setting the
agenda
and they're writing the executive orders
and joe just signs them
this is really their presidency joe
biden
is not in charge you can see it every
day frail
declining weak cognitively struggling
frankly a shell of the guy that he was
ten years ago or even four years ago
seemingly aimlessly roaming the halls of
1600 pennsylvania avenue in between his
naps
and yesterday during what was a
meandering speech
he didn't seem to know what he was even
talking about or
even where he was i'm not making this up
add this to the long montage we have
already put out take a look
challenging the will only to be solved
by nations working together and in
common we can't do it alone
that must be this we must start with
diplomacy
take on directly the challenges posed
by our prosperity security and
democratic values by
our most serious competitor china to
reinvigorate
our leadership on the lgbtqi
issues
going this way thank you all
right which way do i go the lgbqcip
xly oh sorry i'm sorry
well joe wasn't much better today either
gave a speech about the economy
and again today like yesterday lost and
confused or maybe as the song says
dazed and confused take a look it's one
more thing
and i want to say it very clearly on
this be very clear in this point
it's better economics it not only
addresses the immediate crisis we're in
it's better for the long-term economic
health of our nation and our
competitiveness
don't take my word for it just look at
what leading economists across the
nation have said
and in the world and and across the
across the ocean have said
the nonpartisan brooking institution has
looked at the rescue american rescue
plan
and said the gdp that will reach
pre-pandemic projections
by 2021 meaning we'll have recovered by
on
and then a 2021. much sooner by the way
than if we do nothing okay
let's compare that tape to 10 years ago
per usual joe took
zero questions after that train wreck of
a speech
and he's reading the teleprompter and
this weekend he's headed to his family
home in delaware
here for much needed rest and relaxation
he misses his hideaway bunker and the
birds interfering with his prepared
speeches
or his moments with his sunglasses joe's
definitely going to need to recharge
because in just a few days the second
unconstitutional in pgc with a
predetermined outcome
and before passing a covert relief
package or an infrastructure package or
getting kids back to school democrats
will now devote their time their efforts
your money
to another pointless political smear one
last great shot at
former president trump this is what
unity looks like in joe biden's swamp in
washington
democrats play destructive political
games you we the american people you get
left holding the bag